meantime Iran's supreme leader ayatollah
khamenei ii is accusing the country's
enemies of causing the largest protests
against the islamic regime in nearly a
decade according to Iranian state TV 9
more people including a child died
overnight so far the violence has
claimed at least 21 lives more than 400
have been arrested Elizabeth Palmer has
reported from Iran many times and she is
monitoring the protests from London
Elizabeth good morning good morning well
this all started last Thursday with one
isolated protest in a northern city
called Mashhad and it was about food
prices and economic hardship but such as
the pent-up frustration in Iran that
overnight these protests mushroomed and
morphed until now they've affected more
than 50 cities in Tehran crowds
vandalized one of the main shopping
avenues and in city after city people
have come out to protest jeer and throw
stones at the security forces police
have chased demonstrators away with
water cannons in some areas and there
have been isolated reports of shooting
impossible to verify by both the
security forces and the demonstrators
the protesters especially the young and
the working poor are angry about
everything from corruption and
unemployment to lack of freedom and
religious rule they've even been
vandalizing pictures of supreme leader
Ayatollah Khamenei II which is the
ultimate act of defiance in Iran
president Hassan rouhani who's a
moderate went on TV on New Year's Eve
and his response was surprisingly mild
he said people had a right to protest as
long as there was no violence but other
hardline voices are now calling for a
crackdown the authorities are desperate
to get this unrest under control but a
brutal response like the one we saw in
2009 where security forces shot people
in the streets could add fuel to the
fire and turn this into a bloodbath now
I've been speaking to contacts of ours
in Iran this morning they say that in
the cap
things are quiet but very tense
thousands of police on the streets both
uniformed and undercover normally over
the past few days the demonstrations
been getting going around five o'clock
so it's too early to tell whether this
is going to spread even further are
start to fizzle out but of course the
whole world is watching Alex it is
Elizabeth thanks